we're now ready to start the study of
circuit analysis and to design circuits
and analyze circuits one of the things
we need to do is have something to build
circuits with and that's what we're
going to talk about in this video the
idea is we're going to have three
circuit elements the circuit elements
are called resistor
capacitor
it tore
and inductor
okay these are the three
passive or
two element components or circuit
elements that we're going to use to
design a lot of different kinds of
circuits
we're going to first i want to introduce
a symbol for each one of these so we can
talk about it and draw make drawings of
it and first is going to be the resistor
the resistor symbol looks like this it's
a zigzag
line like that
representing
current going through and being resisted
having to do some work another symbol
for resistor looks like this
used in other parts of the world besides
the united states and japan
that's what a resistor looks like and
the symbol we use is r
now for the capacitor
capacitor symbol is actually capacitors
built from two conductors or metal
objects that are placed close together
most capacitors sort of look like that
when they're actually built and the
symbol for a capacitor is a c
and finally for the inductor
we'll do inductors like this
an inductor is actually built from a
coil of wire and so when we draw an
inductor symbol we draw a little coil of
wire like that
and the symbol is l
which is a little odd
it could be called i but the symbol for
i was already taken by
current
which is from the french for intensity
and we couldn't use c for current
because the c is used here so it's a
little quirk of our nomenclature
all right each of these
each of these components has an equation
that goes along with it that relates the
voltage to the current now i'm going to
go back here i'm going to label the
voltages and currents on here
in a very important
convention for drawing circuits let's do
that
when we talk about the voltage on a
component we can label it however we
want plus minus v
and we draw the current
going in
i'll just label a little i there and
we'll do it on all these the current
goes into the positive terminal
the current goes into the positive
terminal so that's v on the capacitor
and
and finally
and the current goes in
and we're going to be very consistent
about this and that's going to keep us
from making mistakes
all right so let's go back to our
resistor and we're going to do the
equation for a resistor what is the
the iv equation for a resistor iv
equation means what relates current to
voltage and for a resistor
it's v
equals
i
times r
so the voltage across a resistor
is equal to
the current through the resistor times
this
constant of proportionality that we call
the resistance this has a very important
name this is called ohm's
law and you're going to use this a lot
so that's ohm's law right there this is
ohm's law
now for the
iv relationship for the capacitor the
capacitor has the property that the
current through the capacitor is
proportional
to the rate of change of the voltage not
to the voltage but to the rate of change
of the voltage and the way we write that
is
current equals
c is the is the proportionality constant
and we write dv
dt
so this is the rate of change of voltage
with respect to time we multiply that by
this property of this device called the
capacitance
and that gives us the current this is
this doesn't have a special name but
it's i'm going to refer to it as the
capacitor equation
so now we have two equations let's do
the third equation which is for the
inductor
the inductor has the property it's very
similar to the capacitor it has the
property that the voltage across
is proportional to the time rate of
change of the current flowing through
the inductor so this is a similar but
opposite of how a capacitor works the
voltage is proportional to
the time rate of change of current and
the way we write that is
voltage equals
l
di
dt
the voltage is proportional the
proportionality constant is the
inductance
the inductance of the inductor
and
this is the time rate of change of
voltage
of sorry the time rate of change of
current
flowing through the
inductor so this gives us our three
equations here they are these are our
three element equations and we're going
to use these
all the time right there those three
equations
one final point i want to make is for
both these equations of components these
are ideal
ideal components
that means these things are mathematical
perfect things that we have in our minds
that we're going to try to build in the
real world but and we'll come close
we'll come very close
we now have a wonderful set of equations
v equals i r
i equals c dv dt
v equals l d i d t these are going to be
like poetry for you pretty soon and
these ideal equations will produce all
kinds of really cool circuits for us